hey guys my name is Jess McDonald as we
probably come to expect today is the
seventeenth month and you're tuned into
gamespot news let's talk video games
first up we have some idea of how long
the watchdog's campaign will be so you
can either rejoice all start riding
those angry letters to ubisoft the
game's creative director Johnathan Morin
took to Twitter to let gamers know that
the average player who roams around a
little bit is likely to finish within 35
to 40 hours he did add though that if
you happen to be something of a
completionist like myself who's a fan of
reading every ATM and knocking off every
side quest your watchdogs playtime is
likely to be closer to a hundred hours
and that's not even including online
play next up all that talk about
titanfall potentially kicking up Xbox
one sales has apparently come to
fruition since cells of Microsoft's
console have doubled in the UK the
shootie Bonanza game itself grab the top
spot in the sales charts followed by
Dark Souls 2 and with that snag the
title for best selling opening weekend
of 2014 so far according to gfk
chart-track who look at things like
numbers and trends so you don't have to
titanfall contributed heavily to
increase console sales with seventy
percent of all Xbox one sales being the
bundle that included the hardware and
the game next up I've got some sony good
news for you and some sony bad news
let's start off with the former Matt
Thorson creator of crazy addictive
action game powerful yes tawa not
tightened has said that PlayStation was
super proactive about bringing the game
to their console the title was
originally made exclusively for the
kick-started android-based kuya console
before sony snagged it and helped the
dev create a version of the game for the
ps4 next up Sony have done themselves in
a little bit today because while we're
used to consoles and games getting
cheaper over time they've decided to
bump up the price of the ps4 and some of
it
games in Canada the official word is
that the fifty-dollar bump from four
hundred dollars to four hundred and
fifty dollars for the ps4 has been made
in order to respond to changes in the
market environment a possible
explanation may be the declining value
of the Canadian dollar but we haven't
had any clarification one way or the
other what we have heard is that
infamous second son and MLB 14 the show
are both set to release at the higher
price of 70 canadian dollars you reckon
is a super uncool of Sony and do you
think there will be any backlash you can
let me know what you think in the
comment section down below or you can do
so on my Twitter where I'm at just
McDonald that is all the stuff that I've
got for you today but thanks for joining
me again and I do have to see you
tomorrow